>> In this session,
we'll have two talks.
One will be a continuation of
what we discussed in
the last workshop,
and then folks from
Sunita will give
an introduction to what
happens in the next session
where we have NGO's
would present problems.
Okay, I'm very pleased to
introduce Professor
Ganesh Ramakrishnan.
This is a project
that got many of us inspired
at the last workshop,
which we held at
ISC, and the goal is
to think about problem
solving in a civic
complaint sense.
All right. So you all have had
problems where you see
portraits on the road,
you see things that don't work
in your city where you live,
and it's often very hard to know
who to contact, how to complain,
and once you make a complaint,
how to follow back
and understand whether
it got solved or not.
Right. And so the Venter solution
that they proposed last year
was a technology solution to
help you make complaints easily,
and then also help you
understand and look
at all the complaints for
a city manager or for us.
I'm very excited to hear
updates from Dr. Ganesh.
>> Thanks for hosting
this workshop,
and I'm glad to see
several of you back here.
So, this is joint work with
Sunita Sarawagi faculty
at IIT Bombay,
and then a couple of students,
graduates, project staff.
This is AI-based complaint
management motivation.
There are several venting
platforms that are extremely
operational flooded with
complains, IChangeMyCity,
SpeakUp, Mumbai basically has
a Complaint Management
System for its own.
Inspired by all of that,
IIT Bombay has also
started a complaint
management system,
and there are many others.
I've highlighted
the first three who
actually are active clients.
One of the complains that
are images, there is text.
Text can be short, text could
have multiple languages
and also mixed code.
Locations, though we have
a separate field for location,
many of these services do
provide separate fields
for locations,
people tend to get all of
that mixed up in
the actual description.
You can see the
descriptions are all,
with images are they're not
completely consistent
with the image itself.
So, these are basically
concerns about cows
eating garbage,
but the text is
something different.
And these are all from
Bangalore incidentally.
So, what's the scale
of these services?
IChangeMyCity with
eight million users
across several cities,
and the range of problems,
lots of different across
these different organizations.
There are also issue such
as fake or spam posts,
which are very specific
to certain organizations
and services.
MCGM, on the other hand,
doesn't have
a very nice interface.
It does provide an interface
for typing in text,
but it has an excellent
complaint routing system.
Each offers a strings
and has limitations.
SpeakUp, again these
are of Bangalore,
is India's first one-stop
feedback platform
not necessarily restricted
to civic problems,
but also banking related
problems, Aadhaar problems.
So they have
several verticals and
feedbacks and all analyze
manually as in
most other services.
Sometimes a feedback tend
to be extremely
emotional so sentiment analysis
becomes quite important,
and there are several
junk oppose as well.
Just to give you
an idea, this is a kind
of contrast SpeakUp complaints.
This is about
high-speed Internet.
This, I think about
some telephone provider.
On the other hand, ICMC is
largely about civic complaints.
So obviously, we can't
provide a solution that
works across all of them.
What we've been evolving is
a platform which all of us could
use and in fact
tune their models.
So, here's how things
were some time back.
The users, there are
these venting platforms
and the civic bodies to whom
these platforms are
routed interestingly.
ICMC routes when several of
its complaints related
to Mumbai to MCGM.
So, where does venter come in?
So, venter also could
stand for vent analyzer.
There are existing
venting platforms
and what we do is use AI
so that citizens
could connect to each
other through a common
shared label space,
so that we realize
two complaints are exactly about
the same issue possibly in
the same location as well,
and also providing tools
for venting platform
to control the AI.
The basically two issues A and B,
I'm going to use those numbers.
So, A is connecting
citizens to others with
the same complaint,
and B are actually tools that we
have been providing
these clients,
ICMC, SpeakUp, and so on.
So that they could
build your own models.
How interactive label
and increment labeling?
Explainable labeling, and
what's all the capability
of designing
simple rules which we
more generally call
labeling functions,
and the whole problem
of label sets evolving
because nothing is static and
fossilized for any of
these organizations.
So, the role that
MSR has been playing
is helping us identify and
connect to social partners.
It has been really handy. Who
would have known who knows
SpeakUp and the issues they had?
Also helping create the bridge
for a dialogue is
also challenging.
This has taken several rounds
of iterations for us to get
some steady-state involvement
with IChangedMyCity.
Recently, we also
came to know that
Amazon has a CC text feedback
classification system.
We started to some extent,
it's what a more
restricted vertical,
but we're really happy to
collaborate the entire week.
It will be very happy
for MSR Sys Sieve
to own up all that you've done.
So, our contribution so far
has been building AI tools and
platforms which are being used.
We also want to connect to
the industrial
experience and MSR to
actually scale it up.
We've been scaling
out to some extent,
but scaling up is a challenge.
So, one of the AI challenges
here, complaints are multi-modal,
this text plus image,
and as I said there may be
inconsistency between what's
tight and what's there in image,
noisy, mixed-language complaints,
"Koi garbage nahi utatha",
and evolving set of issues,
just to give you an idea when
we use some deep networks,
anything that is pulled out
off the shelf doesn't really
work in the Indian context.
So for example, for dogs,
stray, roaming dogs,
etc, are what we learn.
Whereas if you use
pre-trained embeddings,
you have zebra related to a dog,
but as far as zebra would be
more related to a crossing.
Likewise, for garbage, and
these are more examples,
and there are a lot of
sub-tasks that are shared
across complaints.
For example, this is
where we generalize
our solutions across
the different users and clients.
The methodology that can
help them extract problems
and separate them out
from entities about
waste or problem is stated.
We embed all of these
in a continuous space.
Interestingly, we're also able to
embed images in the same
continuous space as a text.
I have sometimes complaints
of only images, that's
another challenge.
That's where
this co-embedding helps.
So, here are examples.
The examples speak
louder than words.
So, we were able
to figure out that
these images are
all about garbage,
but they are in a specific sense
of garbage that they're all
related to cows eating
up this plastic trash,
which is concerns that
responsible citizens have
shared on the platform.
This is another interesting case
"kunda pada hai".
Now, you can see that
the text actually varies
significantly across depots.
This has been here for months.
People have started
dumping more garbage,
whereas near garg stores,
sarai pipal thala, which has
no mention of
the word garbage at all.
So, all these have been mapped
to the garbage category.
Okay. So, what do
we have currently?
Venter service which is exposed,
which is acceptable to decide,
any of these venting
platforms comes to us.
This is great on a conference,
we can do that right away,
and specifically, within IIT,
we're also experimenting
with app-based interfaces
because most of the other
venting platforms
have their own apps.
But what we realize
is these apps also need
to be empowered with AI.
These tags should be
interactively suggested.
Can the user correct
the grammar of
the complaint as he types?
No, all that, we really can't
experiment with some of
these operational
venting platform.
So, we decided to do
that in-house as well.
I'm going to run you through
a very quick video
because that'll give
you everything that is
required to understand.
This what happens, any
of these organizations
can login with
the account as provided.
We use the "Category
Prediction Model".
We kept all the
interaction through
simple CSV files because
that's where they find
it most effective.
We've gone through iterations
to get to you here.
So, in the past, we will
ask them to use our APIs,
but that didn't work out given
the very nature of
these implementations.
Here, what you see is the
spreadsheet that
they have uploaded.
You can see the complaints
and there are
spheres are very specific
to that organization.
They have their
complaint types based
on which we learn
a complaint classifier,
and now what our system
does is once it trains
the model for any new complain,
it will give you a prediction,
the complaint type with
the confidence of that class,
so you can see there are
multiple classes
at drop down list.
The venting platform,
the admin there would
actually correct the label,
and this corrected label
will reflect
in the model that gets updated
after a round of training.
Very something very simplistic
that they're able to use,
all this as I said
is making use of
the learning images and
texts both are handled,
though we have shown
only the text part in
this demo for the sake
of simplicity.
So, you can see, and there
is also color coding
that is used to
improve the user
experience. Okay.
The user can actually upload,
and then the whole thing
gets reflected in
the next round of classification.
So, we have likewise in InstiApp.
Now, the interesting thing
about InstiApp is,
even as the user
types the complaint,
he's able to see
the possible labels,
and the user can actually select,
or unselect one of
the predicted labels based on
what he thinks is appropriate.
So, there's a lot of
semantics lying embodied
in a label, right?
What do you mean by garbage?
It's very different across
people, you're quite surprised.
So, an electric pole
that has fallen
down because of rains
becomes garbage for
some people, right?
So, consistency is
the key issue here.
So, this is how
the InstiApp looks like.
As I said, along with the text,
there is also tags that come up
so that we're able
to come up with
a consensus of
the tax as quickly as
possible without
a long turnaround time.
The interface that we showed,
there's a turnaround
time that gets in
code because the services
become disconnected from
the actual platform.
So, you're trying to do
the tight integration here.
Okay. So, what are
the issues? So, I said
there are two things.
What we have already deployed,
and these are problems
we're working
on for individual organizations.
One of the issues is
involving complaint
classification and ontology.
The label site keeps changing.
So, how can we use AI to let
the venting platforms evolve
their own classifiers and
evolve their own
class labels as well?
So, here you can see entities
like roads, garbage,
animal, streetlights,
and suddenly, drones become
new set of entities,
and that's a reality.
At least in the larger cities,
and then rallies, again
in larger cities.
So, you need to associate
new complain
categories like noisy,
and beggars asking
money, and so on.
In fact, beggars asking money is
a new problem associated with
an old entity that's garbage.
So, you're obviously going
to have the same label set,
catered for all time,
for all organizations.
So, how do they evolve?
So, we have some solutions here,
and also recency matters.
So, what I meant by garbage
at the beginning of creation,
or rather when I
started my platform,
is probably different from
what I mean right now.
So, how do we give
recency more importance?
Again, we use
labeled memory networks
which incorporate a mixture of
simple nearest neighbor
classification,
and the long-term learning
across the legacy data set.
The other thing is finding
an extraction of problems
about an entity.
So, what.
>> So, in different platforms,
and they give you data,
do you continue to update
your own models
collecting from all of
them like what are
the data rights and how
do they react to that?
>> So, we provide a checkbox.
We ask the organization
to let us know
if we could use the data
they're going to in use, right?
So, we need to work
with you on how to
create stricter access controls,
but for the time
being, they're all
happy with this arrangement,
they trust us.
So, only if they
click that checkbox,
we use it to update our model,
otherwise it's theirs.
Thanks. I would really like to
know the right ways
to go about it.
The other thing is why he wants
a particular label assigned
to a particular complaint.
That's all about finding
entity extraction,
highlighting sections
in the complaint
that led to a particular label.
So, garbage not
collected versus garbage
blocking vehicle regular
traffic on a road,
a very different complaint.
They get routed to different
categories though there's
a common entity called garbage.
How do you associate the text in
blue or yellow leading to
different classifiers?
As I can say,
because asking money for garbage.
So, here are the larger context,
in which this, the entity
garbage is being talked about.
So, at least in InstiApp,
what we are providing
right now is
highlighting the section that is
responsible for
a particular label showing
up so that the user has clarity.
Again, our goal is to arrive
at a consensus as
soon as possible.
Then, the other thing we
realize especially if
it's SpeakUp, so SpeakUp,
they're also happy writing
their own small rules for
classification at their end.
Because again the time required
for a model to actually
learn from your training data
could be large.
So, can we use
labeling functions,
a soft keyboard-based labelers?
It's often very easy to associate
the contextual keywords
with the entity,
the actual drive,
the classification.
How would we realize that
the rules in themselves
might be very limited?
When I say, "Garbage
not collected," I also
probably mean that garbage
collection is being ignored,
or there have been gaps
in garbage collection.
So, how do you
expand the scope of
a rule to a continuous
space, right?
So, we'll also, I mean,
certainly we kept research
away from this far distance,
is that right?
But we do realize
research is important,
and in fact, we're quite excited
about some of the work
that has actually come
off from this work.
How do you create
continuous labeling functions?
The human gives
discrete labeling functions,
the machine which is good at
recall makes a labeling function,
or treats it as a continuous one.
This can have implications
in improving recall,
the machines
continuously labeling
space whereas a user is
very good at precision.
Yeah, then you say, what are
the ever-evolving problem list?
Learning from
multi-line license plates
for multiple vehicles in area.
This came from ICMC,
IChangedMyCity.
Sentiment analysis, this
is what SpeakUp wanted.
Identifying "mood" or "tone"
of the complaint using NLP.
Some of these complaints
where suicidal,
I mean suicide notes.
Almost. How do you
prioritize the complaints
based on urgency?
Some of them are
also interested in
correcting the sentence grammar.
Okay. Going forward,
what we would like,
really like to do is more
seriously work with
the CGNet Swara.
We've been in talks with
CGNet Swara for some time,
but I think now we've
stabilized that platform.
We worked reasonably well for
Indian languages,
and also mix code.
We would like to see what we
can do with MSR Sys Sieve,
and yes, that's for Venter.
So, this is about
skilling in rural India,
and this began with our
interaction with the MSR
a year back to the Project Karya,
which was about creating
digital jobs for rural India.
So, the other part is,
we have a very
strong collaboration
between Department of
Computer Science at IIT Bombay,
and there's a center for
technology alternatives
for rural areas, Cithara.
So, the team here is actually
a mixture of Apoorva,
who's here, one of the first
graduates, Apoorva, yes.
She's another first graduate
from the center.
There are software developers
and there are AI guys.
There are lots of
students who are
interested in this work as well.
So, it started with this Project
Karya in 2017 August.
Again, things are clipped
there at the end.
We had, through this interaction,
around 10 students who
typed 4,500 words.
They generated work worth
36,000 rupees, which was good.
We didn't want, one philosophy
we've tried to follow is,
not do any interactions
within the projects.
So, we try to keep the
interaction a live beyond career.
We in fact built a tool,
the team you see,
there are the guys
who actually did
the digital work whom
we had identified,
and then we want them
to be laid down.
So, we actually
developed the tool
which will help them do
interact to OCR because we
got several OCR assignments,
where you have scanned documents,
and you need to get them
into digital format.
But obviously,
no automatic system
is 100 percent perfect.
How do you do OCR post editing?
But what we realized is
there was absolutely
no platform for
accumulating jobs,
identifying the skill
levels of people,
their interest levels,
their time availability.
Doing this matching
was a major issue.
That's when we went
to the second part.
We said, "Well,
all that is fine."
We still have the two, we're
very happy to work with Karya.
We also have
our tool, and we then
talks about integrating the two,
but we said, "How do you do those
need assessment and
solution matching? "
That's when we realize
that Microsoft also has,
specifically MSR has
this Karya, along with Karya,
it has Sangam, Lynda,
a part of Linkedin for
skill development.
All this came to our notice.
So, we're very
interested in seeing
how to tighten
this collaboration at
this of point of time.
But more specifically,
let's understand
this need assessment
and interest matching.
So, most of the solutions that
exist are pushed down, top down.
So, you push
a problem definition,
and then you expect that people
upgrade their skills to match it,
to solve the problems.
However, we realize
that there is lack
of skilling and there's more
seriously a lack of interest
assessment of the people.
Are all field trips,
and in fact we're
quite amazed to see
the amount of work
that already exists,
not only across the globe,
but especially to India,
to very nicely categorize
a people's interests.
So, how do we boost
people's self-confidence?
By reinforcing their skill,
their interests, and also,
we need to create this
strong connectivity industry
that is the forward linkage part,
which is concerned
with placement,
and the backward linkage,
their interest.
Okay. So, we started with
lots of field trips,
village youth interaction,
self-help group
member interactions.
Especially we took up bonds.
A bond is a specific task,
which is of tailoring.
How do you upgrade
the skill levels of tailoring?
We're quite aghast to see
that in the rural sector,
there's lot of talent,
but there's really
no standardization.
So, if there was a big industry
in the area we walked in,
they wanted close to 10,000
uniform stitched over
a period of one month,
and then [inaudible] put
a ban on plastic bags.
>> There was a demand, high
demand for [inaudible] bags.
But absolutely, it was so
difficult to enforce
standardization.
That's when we realized
skill development
and need assessment needs
to be brought together
very closely.
There's also led
us to interaction
with regionals or
college students,
and NSDC Skilling
Center Students.
Interestingly, we realized that
national and
international standards
can all be leveraged.
So, the idea was to interact
locally and scale up nationally,
so the local interaction,
we put in the numbers here,
they may appear to be small,
but that's absolutely
critical for us to
understand, the
qualitative insights.
However, as you see in
the next part, here,
we also leverage
existing national work,
for example, National Career
Service government of India,
it has registered a large number
of job seekers, 42 million,
2015 National
Classification Occupations,
and the number of
listed occupations are
close to 3,000, which
is again large.
Then, the government of India
also refers to Personality Tests,
which have been pretty
much standardized
and some of them are also
part of IBM Watson for,
if you're informed and tried it.
I think MBD is part of
IBM Watson, and so on.
So, at this point, I'll run you
through a demo of
the entire system,
so I request approval to come.
>> So, basically we have
thought of Loka Udyog
in four parts.
First is the Aspiration Finder,
because we found
that in rural areas,
we are targeting
rural youth here.
So, in rural areas,
people are not aware of
what they can aspire for.
So, there is a serious lack
of aspirations.
So, that is one platform
which we are developing,
it is called
the Aspiration Finder.
Where we'll lure the user
through a series
of steps starting from
the Personality Test first,
because these rural youth,
they do not know what kind
of personality they have.
So, we will be having
first, a personality test,
followed by leading them to
different career options,
which they will select from
a series of metrics and this is
based on national and
international codes,
like if you see here,
the second step is knowing
your career aspirations,
I'll just move ahead.
Yeah. So, through
a very simple questionnaire
using graphical format,
we will be asking
the user to answer
the questions and let him know
his career or
his personality type,
and then we will be leading
him to a set of selections,
which he will base
on his interests.
So, this entire thing is based on
the National Glass
classification of occupations.
As you can see,
there is this four digit
code which appears,
and these are national as
well as international codes.
So, basically
the person will be able
to find out where he can fit in.
What kind of occupation will
he be interested in further?
Because what happens
is these youth,
they do not have any knowledge of
what kinds of occupations
their skills can be
translated into.
For example, a person might
be physically very fit,
but he might know how we can
leverage this skill of his.
So, he could very well be
a very good police officer.
So, linking the
person's skills with
their career options and also
considering a parameter
of his interest,
because if there is no interest
in the job that you are doing,
you will not get
any satisfaction out of it.
So, we are just concentrating on
the Japanese concept of Ikigai,
which is exploiting
your reason purpose for being.
So, when we spoke about
this concept to the youth,
they were very much
interested in it, and then,
similar to the first choice,
we will also be giving
him 10 choices mode,
nine other choices in
all 10 career options,
which we feel might
be suitable for him.
But again, just having
the interest is not sufficient,
there should also be aptitude
for going for that
particular occupation.
So, we will be having
some first aptitude tests.
So, this mapping will be done.
Key for what kind of occupations,
what kind of aptitudes
who will require?
So, yeah.
So, this is the
Aptitude Test and then,
it will reel him to
the final career options
without percentage of matching,
and then the user will
also be lead their to
the respective skilling courses
based on where is
aptitudes are lacking.
So, I'll just move ahead now,
this is a job portal,
which we are planning to make.
I'll just mention
two important facts
about the job portal.
One thing is that till
now, there is no,
these rural youth, they
do not know what is
there out in the industry
and what is standard.
So, we will be exposing them to
the National Classification
of Occupation,
which has developed a lot
of qualification packs.
There are sector skill councils
under the government of India,
who have developed a lot
of qualification packs.
So, these are something which we
will be exposing the youth to,
that is point number one.
Point number two is
that we also found that
regional rural colleges do not
have a streamline platform
for placements.
So, in our job portal,
we are going to include
a one module for
educational institutions,
where they can create
their own profile and
link with the industry.
Then there is one last part,
which I will just
quickly move to,
which includes, which is
the success stories module.
We find that in
the rural areas youth
lack motivation and if they
hear good inspirational examples
from their nearby areas,
they get inspired more,
if that person can do something,
why can't I do?
So, we will be covering
these such kind of
inspirational stories.
The first story which you see,
it is off the principal
of that regional college.
>> But just to conclude,
all the four parts,
the components that
Apoorva have talked
about Aspiration
Finder Job portal,
scaling borderland
success stories,
all of them will actually
require AI for matching.
Right from matching to
interactively suggesting as well.
So, the role of AI,
data collection, prediction,
prescription, controlled trials.
So, control trials is what we
plan to roll starting
one month from now,
once we actually
launch the platform.
One of the key aspects here
is how do you when
do automatic resume
building based on
the placement agencies
or the needs of the industries.
How do you capture the intent
of the industries who actually,
may consume the presumably.
These are challenges
we need to work on
in putting the AI models.
We would also like to more
seriously collaborate
with the MSR Sangam Project
at this point of time.
Daria we're already
in docks with Sangam,
for me Sangam actually
also includes Linda.
This is the skill
development platform.
Let us see how that can map
to what the rule aspirations are.
We have very detailed report
on what strings are
rural youth actually
see in manual teaching.
Firstly, teaching with
others ICT for education,
and it's actually a mixture,
a blend of the two
that is going to work.
Neither of them will work
in isolation. Thank you.